I think what,
what we have done at the college board,
if I could explain just a minute about
what the college board is,
because people somewhat kind of confused
about what we are,
what we,
what we are is first is that we're an
organization that is preparing kids to
go to college.
We have this,
we have standards of what you need to
doubt to go to college and be
successful.
We have curriculum from the sixth grade
to the 12th grade and math and English.
We have the AP program,
which is 37 subjects.
So we have a standard,
we have standards and we have,
uh,
programs that allow that.
We prepare kids to go to college.
So we used to be just a,
uh,
individual programs.
Now we're a system of programs that we
can prove that we can really improve
performance significantly and either a
state or school district or in school.
So that's,
that's part of what we do.
The other,
the second part is how do you,
how do you,
how do you affected the admissions
process?
So,
not only do we provide the sat to
colleges and schools and students,
but we also do a lot on financial aid.
We do a lot of admissions.
Part of that's training center that's
programs to help administered.
And the third thing is we have a program
of,
of uh,
of innovation in research.
That's the newest part of the college
board began about three years ago.
We do studies on,
on how you can improve community
colleges,
how you can employ,
prove writing,
how you can improve the process of
getting more students prepared and ready
to go to college.
So that those are the three parts of
the,
of the College Board.
And I think that in Time magazine says
what they did.
It shows that we're trying to make an
impact,
a substantial impact from preparing kids
to go to college,
to the,
the process,
the process of,
of,
of entering college and,
and then looking for ways that we can
improve the whole system by,
by innovation and research.
collegeboard.com was really begun,
um,
really at the sort of the hyper,
the inner internet back about almost as
an been almost nine years ago.
And uh,
I wanted,
when I came to the college board,
one of the first things I did was to
create collegeboard.com cause I wanted
us to be on the cutting edge.
And it's been a really critical part of
the growth and expansion of the,
of the cause.
But when I went to the college where we
had about 400 employees,
we now have about 1200 employees.
We've,
we've,
uh,
we've almost tripled what we've,
what we do today from what we did in
part of that was because we had the
ability to communicate to kids through
the,
to students,
through the Internet system.
So I think it's been a very important,
it's something that we continue to
upgrade.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a good service for parents and
students to better,
better it,
to sign up to get information.
It's,
it's,
it will become a bet bigger and more
important thing for teachers to get
information.
And other educators to get information.
So I think it's,
uh,
it's,
it's highly used.
Uh,
I think it's probably the,
by far the busiest education website in
the country.
And,
uh,
it's given us a chance to speak to
students,
parents,
and teachers and educators in a much
more effective way than we could have if
we hadn't had it.